Announcer: Ladies and gentlemen
please welcome the vice president of products
"at Google, Mario Queiroz."
Good afternoon.
It's great to be here.
Really nice.
Welcome to the Brazilian edition
of Google Developer Day.
this fourth edition of
Developer Day in Brazil.
The number of people interested in attending
our event today was fantastic.
"More than 6,000 people" registered
to fill the one thousand openings
we had for the event.
So we're really pleased
to see such interest
in our development platforms.
It's  a shame that we couldn't
get a few more seats
for those who wanted
to be here with us.
We're going to try to get a few
more chairs in the next hour.
But let's begin with
let's begin with a little
talking a bit about
what we're seeing on the internet.
"But, even before talking about that"
It's been more than 20 years
since I left Brazil
and that's why it's great to be here
but I've been keeping up with
what's going on back home
when there's a game in Brazil
when theres a world championship
my shirt's still yellow
and I'm proud of the yellow shirt
even when we don't play very well
and even when we lost
"to the Netherlands, in June,"
But there's always another championship
the next one we'll win
I'm sure.
Speaking a little more seriously
the Brazilian economy that we
that I read about
certainly ouside of Brazil itself
is going through a
"very, very good period"
a that the Brazilian technological stage
is getting more and more interesting.
what you see in this chart is
we see 76 million
online users in Brazil
that's
Brazil is 5th in world rankings
in terms of the number of online users
"and Latin America, too,"
has been growing a lot.
We've seen a 21% growth
according to this source here
that the number of online users in Latin
America from May 2009 to May 2010
"It's the region, it's the geography"
that has grown the most worldwide.
And I know that much of the talent
of the engineers of Brazil
of the computer scientists
of Brazil are in this room today.
We're really grateful and very
honored that you've chosen
to spend the day with us today.
I'm going to talk a little about
sharing our vision with developers.
and I hope that these sessions you'll be
participating in today can also be
very advantageous to you
One request we were showing
on the screen when you came in
is to you turn off the hotspots
from your Androids from your device
during our keynote presentation
because we're going to do demos
that require a network with no fields and
the demo will run better if you
aren't running hotspots
So I ask that you
follow this request
And before beginning with
the keynote presentation
that I and a few of my colleagues
will give
colleagues from Google
and also our partners
I'd like to announce to you
I almost made the announcement
I skipped
I skipped to the next slide;
some of you may have already seen
a little bit of
what I'm going to talk to you about.
We heard from the developers
of apps for Orkut
I imagine there are quite a few here
that monetization is very important and
that we didn't have a solution for it.
In August of this year
Google bought
a business called Jambool.
that's a business that had and has
a platform for monetization
And we were really happy
to be able to announce the support of
"Orkut in Brazil, through Jambool."
and we are announcing this today
here in Brazil
This means that the developers
can add virtual goods
quickly to their applications
with low set-up effort
some details of today's announcement
is that in addition to the credit card
Jambool of Brazil offers
support for Boleto Bancario
The whole experiece
has been tailored to Portuguese
"Brazilian Portuguese, of course"
with 24/7 support
And all this with a low 10% rate
that allows most of the reciepts to go directly
to the developer and not to Google.
You can find out more
information about Jambool
in a presentation today here
a presentation called
The Open and Social Web
that Patrick [inaudible] will give.
We're very happy
to be able to announce this.
But let's get to our main presentation.
During the day we'll be talking about
Google's efforts to make sure
"that the internet with platforms,"
mobile networks
and the infrastructure of Cloud computing
are all better and faster
There are big investments in these areas
and we'll cover three topics here
in the keynote.
One is Chrome and HTML5
"Then, Eric Tholome, my workmate"
will talk about the infrastructure
of Cloud Computing.
and then I'll be back to talk about Android
We've got a few demos
we're going to show you
during the presentations
I hope you'll find them interesting.
"I'm going to begin, then,"
with Chrome and HTML5
Time spent online
The web is really the most important
platform of our generation.
You can see that internet use
has more than doubled in the last 5 years
We're talking about the period
from 2004 to 2009 here
while other platforms
either stalled or even decreased.
And we see that the web apps
thanks mainly in large part due to
"HTML5 in the last 18 months, 2 years"
have become much more powerful
in many ways.
"New browsers like Chrome,"
or new versions of Firefox
"of Safari, of Internet Explorer 9"
have added HTML5 APIs
if you're using those APIs
They allow new ways to use
like powerful graphics
integration with the desktop
hardware integration
we're going to show you
several features
in this presentation here
and throughout the day.
HTML5 has only been around
for less than two years
and it keeps gaining ground
This was the situation 18 months ago
looking at support for HTML5
"It got off to a good start,"
but was lacking a lot
And today
a few short 18 months later
we see this
completely different view
On the part of all the browsers support
"for us, for video, for WebGL,"
and for web storage
and other areas...
Nevertheless
beyond the browsers
we also see the frequent use
of HTML5
by browsers on smartphones.
And that's what we're going to talk
a little more about
about its growth in the mobile field.
So the path we've been following
shows a lot of progress in that area.
"as a result of these changes, many"
developers are looking for the web
looking at the web as a platform
for innovation
And it
Because it
it's important
we see that it's very important
that the web offer
as many features as
native operating systems
Here we're going to start
talking now a bit about
specific cases and specfic features
Up to now
the platform was limited with respect to
that kind of feature.
But with HTML5
we keep working
"we here at Google, as much as everyone"
"in the community, to improve it"
We're going to begin with graphic support
Games developed and multimedia apps
are now using technologies
"like Canvas, like WebGL"
and hardware acceleration
is using more and more GPU
"HTML5, since it's "
it has more system operations capacity
available
and now we have more and more
APIs to access a microphone.
to access the harddrive
to access the acclerometer
that every computer has
"for example, within the harddrive"
"So, no"
I'm going to ask my colleague to come up
to talk about hardware access
"my friend, Eric Bidelman"
Eric Bidleman
he's on the Google Chrome team
will give a few demonstrations for you
He'll--
He practiced Portuguese a lot
these last couple of weeks
but he's going to give his presentation
in English.
If you have the headsets
you got when you came in
for simultaneous translation
if you'd rather--
But right now I'm going to call Eric
to come up to give us a few demos.
"Please, Eric."
"Obrigado, Mario."
"Bom, eu acho que uma das coisas mais "
interesantes do HTML5 é a capacidade grafica.
Agora a gente pode
"usar graficos em 2D, 3D  "
e estao acelerados pelo hardware
É bem interesante.
"Bom, eu acho que uma das coisas mais "
interesantes do HTML5 é a capacidade grafica.
Agora a gente pode
"usar graficos em 2D, 3D  "
e estao acelerados pelo hardware
Se ouviu falar do HTML5
voces devem ter ouvido falar
do canvas tag
O canvas tag com uma só tag
e umas linhas de Javascript
voce pode servir um conteúdo rico
para os usuários
e é muito interativo.
Deixa mostrar o que é que eu quero dizer.
Bom. Isso está usando o canvas tag
Isso está processando com Javascript
Tem o gosto do filme the Matrix
se podem recordar desse filme
Mas eu interactuo com a mouse
"e quando faço isso, o text"
está updating ao vivo.
Tudo isso está usando Javascript no canvas
O que é que podemos fazer
perdão
Tambem tem jogos
que voce pode fazer com Canvas
E este jogo se chama Galactic Inbox
Está construído à base do Gmail
e eu vou tentar
quando ele mais rapido aqui
Voces podem ver
podem ver que estamos
conectando com a teclagem
estao descendo
nao esta nada lento
tudo se ve em tempo normal real ao vivo
dando tiros no spam quando ele chega
e vem voando.
Aí está o spam
Já entenderam como é
Conteúdo interactivo e divertido usando o Canvas
Mas podemos continuar mais além disso
Entao isso tambem é o Canvas
mas isso aqui é Canvas 3D
"Entao, como mencionou o Mario"
podemos ligar com o WebGL
que usa OpenGL ES2.0 no web
em Javascript
E eu vou mudar para o Chrome
Entao este primeiro demo é de uma galería
de fotos
patrocinado pela
gente lá na Cool Iris.
Estes são a mesma pessoal que
desenvolveu app de fotos para o Android
a galería no aparelho Android
A diferencia aqui é que isto
é um aplicativo da web
Entao eu posso interactuar com ele
usando eventos por toque
Eu posso pasar por aqui
Voce pode ver uma reflecao linda
umas sombras
voce pode magnificar o conteúdo
É rápido
Perfome
é porque está usando
hardware acelerado
Um toque bonito que eles fizeram
com esse demo
foi de conectá-lo com a busca de imagems
de Google
Está iqual a pegar as coisas no instante
e ainda preve no momento atual.
Um grande exemplo de usar WebGL
Vamos olhar de outra perspectiva
para presentar o conteúdo
Entao voces podem ver aqui na tela
Aqui tenho uma esfera
Tem muitas fotos cargadas
Eu posso girá-la em real time
"Está indo muito rápido porque, "
está acelerado no hardware.
Mas para dar a prova para voces
Eu vou diminuir o tamanho
dessas imagems
e trocá-las por umas
e espero
se tudo sair bem
isto vai rodar tao rapido quanto
a aceleracao no hardware
Voces podem ver que a frame rate
baixou um pouco
Isto é porque estamos
temos centenas de fotos
Mais um demo WebGL
Espero que isso nao seja
uma imagem da Terra ao vivo
Mas agora temos um asteroid
caindo na Terra
explodindo
Posso colocar umas a mais
quando entram
Mas se eu realmente quero
fazer um jogo mais interesante
posso adicionar muitos mais
E isso está funcionando com
de novo
está usando aceleração no hardware.
a GPU do computador
Voce pode ver que está
um pouco mais devagar
mas
voces podem ver
que estamos batalhando bem forte
com a Terra
Entao é isso WebGL.
Como falou o Mario
nao é só de graficos.
Tambem tem acesso ao file e hardware
Entao tem melhor integração com o OS
As coisa que podiam fazer native
no aplicativo
voce pode agora fazer na web
Vou mostrar para voces do que
eu estou falando.
HTML5 tem a posibilidade de
fazer drag-and-drop
drag-and-drop native
dentro do navegador
Mas tambem pode fazer drag-and-drop
do desktop para o navegador
Agora tenho umas imagems aqui
no meu directory local
e eu posso agarrá-las
do Mac para o aplicativo do web
E voce pode ver que aqui estão rendered
Tudo isso usa o file reader API
Eu ja li os files com Javascript
e criei as imagems pequenas
E tomei um paso a mais para
fazer umas CSS transforms
e animações
Então voce pode criar
pode imaginar a criar uma galeria
ou mostrador bem interesante.
Outra coisa que pode fazer
com HTML5
que é ler um diretório enteiro
recursivamente
Isto é um input tag simple
Ao adicionar a atributa do directório
voce pode fazer
algumas coisas incríveis
Entao aqui neste demo
tehno um file picker
Posso escolher uma só ficha
Posso escolher um diretorio enteiro
E eu
o que ganho é que eu posso
ler o diretório enteiro recursivamente
Talvez voce tenha
um MP3 ou tipo assim
Poderosos resultados
com a mínima de code
Vamos voltar para ver isso
em full screen
Outro modo de ligar com
o hardware é com a voz
Claro que temos a teclagem
para interactuar
mas agora temos a possibilidade
de usar a voz para input
para fazer coisas diferentes
com a accesibildade
E agora é assim que a gente
ve google.com
ao menos na liga dos dot com
E voce pode ver que
tem algo diferente com isso aqui
"Então, no canto direito dessa caixa de "
entrada tem um microfonezinho.
"E, claro que eu posso teclar aqui"
na caixa e fazer a busca
ou posso usar o microfone.
"Sheraton Hotel, São Paulo, Brazil"
Entao ao usar uma só atributa
não tem nada de Javascript aqui
voce pode ver que fez umas pesquisas
"de voz para mim, em tempo real."
Muito legal.
O últiimo demo que vou mostrar
é um API para a orientação do aparelho.
e isto é para mim uma das coisas
mais interesantes
Entao voce pode ver ums
numeros mudando na tela
e é porque esta mesa
não esta nivelado
Mas isto esta lendo
os dados do acelerometro do laptop
E com umas linhas breves de Javascript
Eu posso aplicar a transformação CSS
neste div aqui
e vou mostrar para voces como é
"Bom, eu posso tentar nivelar isto"
muito legal
[aplausos]
Esperem.
Tem mais.
"Bom, isto é o Chrome do Google"
uma marca que todos chegamos a amar
Voces viram isso no div
mas pode ir um paso mais alem
e fornecer um contúdo
bem interativo para os usuários
Isto tambem usa tranformações de CSS3
e a API da orientação do aparelho
E voce tem
e pode ver o z index aí.
Muito legal.
Para terminar com HTML5
reconhecemos que temos capacidade
de video
temos o canvas tag para graficos
e combinando tudo isso podemos
incorporar uma biblioteca de fisica
uma biblioteca de fisica por Javascript
e o API da orientacao do aparelho
[musica]
Entao isto é o video do HTML5
reproduzido nos blocos individuais
E usando o API da orientação do aparelho
Eu posso virar o mundo
[musica]
Bem legal.
E voce pode ver que o video
ainda toca emquanto eu fizer isso.
Isto tudo esta  acontecendo em tempo real
usando HTML5
usando Javascript
usando a orientação do aparelho
e Canvas
Vamos ver isso de novo
E tao legal.
Levanta e deixa cair
Bem bacana
Entao é tudo para mim.
Vou devolver o palco ao Mario
[aplausos]
So we're really
very excited
with our demos and
with lots of other things
that we see happening
with the new APIs.
But every good thing has its challenges.
And we think that we understand
many of the challenges faced
by developers like you for web apps
that's another reason to have an event
like this one to talk with you
and understand what you
most want to work on
with Google and how you
want to work with these APIs.
"Specifically, three of the challenges"
we see are in the area of ...
"First, the discovery of web apps."
There is
so much interest
"there are so many applications that you, "
want to know how to reach
the greatest number of users.
So that users can
discover your applications.
And when the user discovers
an application
you want the user to continue
to rediscover that application
and use it more and more.
You want to know how to survive
doing what you adore doing
what you love to do
which is programming.
And so monetization is very importnat.
We took these considerations
into account
we kept this in mind in order to project
and build our online store for Chrome.
We still have a...
We still don't have a version
"to share with you,"
but we're working
to fix these challenges that I'm talking
about making the applications
easier to be discovered and
"make rediscovery easy,"
the reuse of the application.
And also to make it possible
for the paid applications
as much as for the free applications.
You can get ready for when
the store opens at the end of this year.
There's not much time left to create
and upload your web apps
on the Chrome developer dashboard.
And we hope
that the development of Chrome
of the Chrome store
of the Chrome store is as successful as
the development
of the browser itself
has been.
We see
we saw the Chrome browser surpass
more than 70 million users worldwide.
that's a big number and the rate
of growth is really very fast.
I want to also mention that Brazil
is the second country in the world
in numbers of adopters of Chrome
in absolute volume of the adoption
of Chrome.
that is something that makes us
very proud.
So the web platform
really is the most powerful
plaform today
with the advances in HTML5.
And we're very
we will continue to invest a lot in this area
to continually improve
"the Chrome browser, and all of"
all the features
that we've shown here.
that we're going to demonstrate today
"as much for the users, of course,"
that the most important thing
is that we deliver
applications that are
good for the users.
"But, of course, also "
for you.
"And now, let me introduce "
our second keynote speaker.
Eric Tholomé.
He's going to show you
what we're doing in the area
of cloud computing infrastructure.
Eric and I worked together
in Europe a long time ago.
He tried to teach me French.
it didn't work very well.
I tried to teach him Portuguese.
"That didn't work very well, either."
His Portuguese
is much better than my French.
But he'll also give his talk in English.
"So at this time, if you want to use "
the headsets to hear his presentation
you can.
"So, Eric, please."
[applause]
"Bom dia, todos."
"Estou muito, muito alegre"
de estar aqui hoje em Sao Paulo
e dá muita emoção
ver tantos de voces.
Eu vi algumas pessoas já nos corredores
às 7:30 da manhã.
É impresionante.
"Obrigado pela sua interês, "
sua paixão pela web.
Mario falou de quanto rápido está
desenvolvendo os browsers e as normas
"E, como voces sabem, quando voce"
cria um aplicativo para a web
precisa de browsers e código front-end
mas tambem precisa de servidores e redes
para entregar a parte back-end.
E geralmente referimos a essas coisas
como cloud computing.
"Por isso, vou tomar ums minutos"
para falar de
como está desenvolvendo esse mundo
muito rápido e emocionante.
"Mas primeiro, vamos dar uma olhada"
de onde todos chegamos.
E não vou falar de macacos
nem todos estão de acordo que
descendemos de macacos.
Eu quero falar de computadores.
"E, se recordam,"
tudo começou com os mainframes.
Se olham para
toda a inovacao que aconteceu
e que tem criado o mundo em que
"vivemos hoje, que veem na tela"
e se voces pensam na velocidade
no aumento de poder do CPU
e o tamanho da memoria que temos visto
cada 10 anos pasamos por
uma revolucao no mundo de computar.
E essa revolucao tem
mudado dramaticamente cada vez
o método de criar aplicativos.
"E, como voces todos sabem, "
se estao aqui hoje
a revolucao mais recente
que estamos pasando é o cloud computing.
É essa a promesa que voces
nao vao ter que preocuparse
com RAM e CPU e discos
e tal.
E voce vai poder comprar
e consumir a computacao pela internet.
Igual a que voces compram os mp3
ou camara digital ou brinquedos online.
Na Google
para fazer com que essa promesa
se realize
"no ano 2008, lançamos um produto"
chamado Google App Engine.
A promesa que o Google App Engine
entrega é para fazer muito mais facil
e mais rápido construir seus aplicativos;
para dirigir seus aplicativos
para escalar seus aplicativos
Quando voce usa o App Engine
ou se voce somente escreve programacao
Voce nao tem que preocuparse com RAM
e CPU e discos
e um monte de hardware
agora.
Quando voce estiver pronto
"basicamente, aperte o botao"
e aí voce tem um aplicativo
Está vivo
É escalável.
Está no internet
E nao ha nada com que se preocupar
em termos de manutenção ou escalabilidade.
Estou alegre para reportar
que durante os últimos dois anos e meio
desde que o App Engine naceu
temos visto crecimento muito grande.
"Nesses días, ums 90 mil desenvolvedores"
usam o App Engine no mundo enteiro.
Eles tem construido ums 130 mil
aplicativos que estao vivos cada dia.
"e servem mais de 5,5 bilhões de"
páginas vistas cada semana.
Esses são números impresionantes.
"E para nós no Google,"
"particularmente o time de App Engine,"
"tem sido muito, muito gratificante"
ver tantos novos websites
tantos novos aplicativos
tantos novos negocios aparecerem
e serem mais rápido à inovação
"e ao mercado, graças ao App Engine."
E a grande coisa é que isso
está acontecendo por tudo o mundo.
Mas tambem um pouco disso
está acontecendo aqui no Brasil.
Tem histórias de sucessos estupendos
vindo do Brasil.
E quero convidar o Marcelo Marzola
o CEO e um dos fundadores da Predicta
e BTBuckets
para participar no palco e falar para nós
e para voces de sua história de sucesso.
Marcelo Marzola
[applause]
"Thank you, Eric."
You're welcome.
"Hello, everyone."
Hello.
"In Portuguese, a little, now."
My name is Marcelo.
I'm the CEO of Predicta.
We are a business that develops
technology for online marketing.
We've got 10 years of stories.
We are 120 professionals in the business today.
And I have to say that it's my
pleasure to work every day
with some of the best
developers in Brazil.
Some of them are here.
Buyt I didn't come to talk with you
today about Predicta.
"I wanted to alke about our youngest child,"
BTBuckets.
an experience that was born
from inside Predicta
more or less at the same time that
cloud computing history began
to happen around the whole world.
We wanted to have some experience
with cloud computing
so we took
one of our areas of expertise
that's a business called
behavioral segmentation
and we went looking for a structure
for cloud computing
that could handle this platform.
We came to App Engine more or less
at the same time that App Engine was born.
To tell our story of...
"Preciso dos diapositivos, por favor..."
to the the strory of
"of how BTBuckets grew,"
I decided to call my friend
that you see on the screen.
And I wanted to ask if anyone
knows who that guy is on the screen?
Raise your hand if you know him.
No?
No one?
What's his name?
Wagner.
This is Wagner.
Wagner is one of our
infrastructure engineers.
He's been working with us for 5 years
and two weeks ago
Wagner came up to me and said...
"he stopped me in the hallway and said,"
"Marcelo, I'm leaving the company."""
[He rolled his eyes]
"I love this company,"
"I love what I do, but I feel like"
you're paying me
for something I'm not doing.
So I think it's best if I leave the company.
I took my phone out of my pocket
and took a picture of him.
He understood that...
This is the photo.
"I asked him,"
"""Can I use your photo on a DVD?"""
"He said, ""Sure."""
And that's why it's there.
Our online infrastructure engineer.
Infrastructure engineers are important
because they bring credibility
to the infrastructure.
And when you're selling applications
when we developers
are selling applications
coming to clients
conferring credibility
in the infrastructure is important.
And to pass on the credibility
we had to arrive with a speech
more or less like this
[ ] seen some place.
"Or, then, a diagram of a complicated "
network like this.
"Today, when we want to pass along credibility,"
what we do is show a turbine.
A turbine is universal.
We manage to meet with
clients from all around the world
and show them that we use
App Engine and know that
that client has faith
in the structure we're using
"to run our application,"
our platform.
"Credibility is important, but "
it isn't everything.
We also have to
"look at profitability, too."
"So, for the two indicators"
of profitability
that for any one who works with
developers are important.
"On the left, we talk "
about development time
"on the right, we talk"
about cost.
To build an infrastructure
"for one of our platforms,"
"throughout our business,"
we discovered that we took
more or less about 10 months.
"With App Engine, we managed"
to use more or less
2 months of time
for infrastructure development.
"Oh, another important thing:"
when I talk about development
I'm talking aobut the whole process
from application
building the infrastructure
and everything else.
But with App Engine
a real case that happened
with us
more or less about
2 or 3 months ago
we reached our allotment limit
for App Engine.
We brought up the form;
we filled in the form.
"We said, ""Everyone, we've blown our limit."
We need more computational power.
"The next day,"
"less than 24 hours,"
our infrastructure capability
had been multiplied by four.
For anyone here
who has an application
who's already run a data center
who's already managed a data center
We at Predicta
have managed many
you know how complicated
and different this is.
when you're running
your own infrastructure.
Cost of development
"300 thousand reais, more or less, "
to put up a cool infrastructure.
to run a web application
with quality
low maintenance
good response time
Using App Engine:
15 thousand reais.
15 thousand reais is more or less
I think I can say that it's
an amount of money that any one of us
here in this room could raise
to build an application and get
something running on the web.
From 300 to 15 thousand.
Global reach.
It's not setting up a data center
here in Brasil
to serve Brasil.
You can serve the whole world.
And when we say
the whole world
this is a map of worldwide users
of BTBuckets today
And I think that that's what we try
"to do with developers,"
like Brazilians
"and as developers, take"
the name of Brazil
out and take our
thake the quality of our movement out.
And so I invite you
to also use App Engine
and take Brazil's name out.
That's what I wanted to say to you.
Thank you.
Great.
"Thank you, Marcelo."
"Espera. Espera, espera."
Acabei de encontrar você no nosso
sistema interna esta manhã
e você não é somente um dos nossos
"clientes mais grandes no mundo,"
mas acabei de descubrir que você é o nosso cliente
mais grande no Brasil para o AppEngine.
Já sabía disso?
"Não, não sabía."
Quando foi que vocês lançaram o BTBuckets?
Mais ou menos há 18 meses
Estes caras tem ido de zero
ao mais grande cliente do AppEngine
no Brasil em 18 meses.
Isso é incrível.
Parabems.
Thank you.
[aplausos]
Vocês acabaram de ouvir de Marcelo
"numas historias muito precisas, verdadeiras"
como é que AppEngine fez dirigir
um negocio com mais facilidade.
Se você perguntar aos
CIOs e administradores de IT
eles vão dizer que gastam mais ou menos
60% do custo em manutenção.
em que chamamos de manter as luzes acesas
de consertar as falhas dos servidores
e hardware
em applicar remendos
que pode receber cada X semanas
Não sería bom se pudesse
usar todo esse dinheiro
todo esse investimento para inovação?
Se pudesse injectar esse 60%
em desenvolvimento
em vez de gastá-lo
em manutenção?
A outra coisa que é muito bom é que
com AppEngine
você pode inovar mais rápido
porque está focado no
"código, em vez do resto."
Mas a grande coisa é que
o próprio AppEngine faz invovação muito rápido
E vou tomar ums minutos para
falar de algumas dessas coisas grandes.
que vão chegando no AppEngine.
"Primeiro, para demostrar"
quanto rápido muda a plataforma.
Não faz mais de ums meses atrás
lançamos a funcionalidade de namespaces.
"Com isso, trazemos novas capacidades"
que permitem multi-tenancy em AppEngine.
E se olhamos para o futuro
aquí estão algumas das coisas
que vão chegar no AppEngine.
Apoio completo para MapReduce.
Isso significa computação paralela
diretamente do AppEngine.
Importar e exportar em grande quantidade
do datastore
para que possa mais facilmente
transferir seus dados para o AppEngine.
quand faz rodar o aplicativo.
E tambem tirar os dados quando for necesario.
"""reserved instances' vai "
deixar reservar os instantes
"como diz o nome, para asegurar"
que o seu app sempre responde
o mais rápido posível
a um pedido de qualquer usuário.
Servidores de fundo vão deixar que as funções
continuam a funcionar por um peridodo indefinido
em vez de parar
por causa dos time-outs da plataforma.
Com a API RealTime Channel
você recebe uma maneira muito interesante
para que o seu app interactue
"com o usuário usando ""browser push"""
você pode atuar com os usuários
no momento
que dá outras posibilidades
de comunicação.
"E, finalmente, vamos adicionar"
o suporte para OpenID e OAuth.
Essas são duas especificações emergentes
que são cada vez mais importantes
quanto à autenticação.
E tudo isso é muito estimulante.
Tambem percebemos que quanto mais
os desenvolvedores e negocios dependem do AppEngine
como o BTBuckets
é importante que alcançamos
suas normas
e novas necesidades chegam.
É por isso que no Maio
deste ano no Google IO
anunciamos Google AppEngine
para Negocios.
E desde então estivemos trabalhando
muito para fazê-lo disponível
O AppEngine para Negócios é...
"Basicamente, "
cria na mesma plataforma.
É o AppEngine que já conhecem.
Entrega na promesa
"de fazer fåcil a construção,"
"a manutenção, e a escalabilidade"
dos aplicativos.
Mas tambem
AppEngine para Negócios vai trazer
um acordo de nível de serviços
"É, basicamente, escrevendo com palavras"
"que os advogados gostam, nosso compromiso"
que vocês conhecem bem
de colocar à disposição os produtos
de alta disponibilidade.
AppEngine para Negócios
vem com suporte profesional
porque quando o seu negócio
começa a contar com um produto
como o AppEngine
é importante saber
que podem comunicar com a gente
e que tem um tempo de resposta
garanitda.
App Engine para Negócios
vem com Hosted SQL
porque sabemos
que muitos desenvolvedores
conhecem e realmente gostam da SQL particularmente
no mundo enterprise para aplicativos internas.
App Engine para Negócios terá uma
caracteristica de seguridade by default
Isso quer dizer que se você está montando
um aplicativo interno
a plataforma si mesma vai garantir
que somente os seus funcionarios vão ter
acesso aos aplicativos internos.
Não vai ter que preocuparse
com autenticação ou leaks.
O normal será que seus aplicativos
estarão seguros no seu domínio.
"Da mesma maneira, você vai poder"
usar SSL com seu domain
para que os dados da companhía para
seus aplicativos serão cifrados
desde os navegadores dos usuários
até o seu aplicativo.
"E, finalmente, o App Engine para Negócios"
vem com um console de administração
Parece assim.
Quando você é um CIO
ou um administrador de IT
"você tem dezenas, centenas, e"
"às vezes, miles de aplicativos."
E se tem plataformas múltiples
e servidores múltiples
pode ser muito complexo
para controlar tudo isso.
Quando usam App Engine
para Negócios
você tem um lugar central
para configurar
e controlar o acesso
e politicas de seguridade.
É isso que o Console de Administração
tenta fazer.
"Então, o Cloud é maravilhoso."
Você pode prestar atenção na inovação.
Tudo mundo está feliz.
Mas normalmente tem uma pergunta
que tem as pessoas.
"É, 'Bem, você sabe,"
é seguro escholher O Cloud?'
Estou pronto para O Cloud?
O Cloud está pronto para mim?
"E se eu trocar de idéia, sabe, "
qual é a segurança que tenho
se quero sair do seu Cloud
ou um Cloud qualquer
eu vou poder sair?
E isso é uma boa pergunta.
"Quero dizer, quantos de vocês podem dizer"
que nunca estiveram trancados dentro da tecnología
sem perceber?
Você para de construir usando linguagem
nas plataformas grandes ou com ferramentas
e daí você percebe que
se quer mudar de idéia
é difícil.
Levanta a mão
se isso nunca aconteceu com você.
Não vejo nenhuma mão.
Uau
Achei que algumas pessoas
pensam que nunca acontecería com eles.
É por isso que
"no Google, um dos prinípios fundamentais"
de design
e isso é verdade para todos os produtos
do Google
e é bem verdade no caso do nosso
produto de cloud computing
App Engine.
Concentramos na transparencia de informação
Aonde for e quando for posível
Usamos padrões abertos
para que vocês possam levar seu app
"o seu código, e seus dados com vocês."
Na verdade gente vai mais além dos padrões
Padrões são uma boa base para isso
Mas o que temos feito
é que trabalhamos com as ferramentas
de desenvolvimento
e com os nossos porters para entregar
o que chamamos de portabilidade de cloud.
A idéia de portabilidade de cloud
é que pode montar seu app
sem ter que preocuparse com
que vai lançá-lo no nosso cloud
"num outro cloud, ou na premise."
E é somente na hora de lançar
que você escolhe
onde você quer lançar e
pode mudar de idéia.
É essa a máxima promessa
de portabilidade e abertura de cloud.
Quero tentar ser um pouquinho
mais específico com essa situação.
Provavelmente estão perguntando por que
estão vendo vinho e queijo.
A razão principal
"é que, como falou Mario,"
"sou francês, e isso é uma promoção"
dos produtos melhores do meu país.
Estou tentando
fazer uma comparação aquí
e tinha outra opção
que foi colocar um campo de futebol
mas pensei com mil brasileiros
e somente eu
a única pessoa francês
que provavelmente sería um pouco arriscado.
"Inclusive, eu ainda recordo"
a Copa Mundial com muita dor.
Então escolhí vinho e queijo.
E o que quero dizer com vinho e queijo
é que você conhece o grande sabor de vinho
e tambem o sabor delicioso de queijo.
Mas quando você come as duas coisas juntas
é ainda muito melhor.
"Bem, foi exatamente isso que aconteceu"
quando encontramos com a gente de VMWear
"no ano passado, mais ou menos um ano atrás."
E acabaram de adquirir o Spring.
E o VMWear e o Spring são dois líderes
em desenvolvimento de software de empresa.
"E vimos que tinham fabricado, êles e nós, "
umas ferramentas incríveis para desenvolver
que separados eramos muito boms
mas se combinamos os dois juntos
se integramos os dois
resultaría uma coisa
ainda melhor.
As ferramentas a quais estou referindo
"são o Google Web Toolkit,"
que é uma ferramenta muito útil
para construir e montar a parte front-end
de um site usando a linguagem Java
e SpringRoo.
SpringRoo é a ferramenta de desenvolvimento
para montar os back-ends de negócios.
E como podem imaginar
se juntam os dois
e fazer com que eles se emendam
o resultado é um ambiente de desenvolvimento
bem facinante
para criar um aplicativo
bom e moderno para o web.
E é isso em que trabalhamos quando
nos conhecemos mais ou menos um ano atrás
E estou muito emocionado
para anunciar que a partir de ontem
as novas versões dessas ferramentas
funcionam juntas e estão geralmente disponíveis.
E para fazer ainda mais específico
do que vinho e queijo
eu vou convidar o Chris Reimsdale
o nosso enginheiro de desenvolvimento
de programas no Google
para vir ao palco e dar para nós
um demo dessas ferramentas.
Chris Reimsdale.
[aplausos]
"Obrigado, Eric."
"Bem, se vamos fazer fácil"
"lançar, escalar, e dar apoio"
"ao seu web app no cloud,"
temos que fazer com que
é fácil de desenvolver também.
Como eu já faleir
"nos últimos meses, temos trabalhado"
com VMWare
e Spring para juntar um bom conjunto
de ferramentas de desenvolvimento.
E uma dessas ferramentas de que falou
foi o SpringRoo.
Spring Roo é uma fantástica utilidade
de command line
para gerar e manter
muito do código repetido
para montar os applicativos da web.
E prestava muita atenção
ao back-end.
Agora com a intergração
com o Google Web Toolkit
o que pode agora fazer
é criar aplicativos da web maravilhosos
que estão construido com HTML5 e Ajax
para dar uma experiencia muito bom ao usuário
Agora para ver isso em ação
eu vou passar à utilidade
"de command line, SpringRoo"
e tenho um monte de controles
disponíveis.
Mas a maneira mais fácil de começar
é usar uma das scripts
que enviamos junto com SpringRoo.
Vamos usar o exemplo de gastos
que temos aquí.
E o que vão ver é que o Spring Roo
gerou muito código para mim.
Está gerando o meu projeto.
Está gerando um persistence layer.
"Está gerando os aspectos, o controlador."
Está gerando um arquivo
para controlar todas as dependencias
E finalmente está gerando
o applicativo da web.
Aí está.
"E, no final,"
tenho um aplicativo.
"Tenho o front-end,"
o backp-end.
E posso rodar esse aplicativo
do command line
usando ferramentas da indústria
tais como o Maven.
É bem simples.
Mas para mostrar um pouquinho mais do demo
"vamos passar ao ID,"
"afinal, adoramos as ferramentas."
Então isso é o conjunto de ferramentas
do SpringSource.
O IDE de Spring.
"Está montado no Eclipse,"
e tem entradas de integração
com o plug-in de Google.
E podemos ver que
porque o aplicativo já está
instalado no IDE.
E aí está.
O aplicativo My Expenses.
"Agora, para rodar, somente tenho que"
"apertar ""run as"""
"""web application"""
e o plug-in
do Eclipse vai asumir o controle.
E então vai começar a carregar
ums dos componentes no IDE.
E finalmente vai dar
um URL
que pode usar dentro do navegador
para carregar o aplicativo.
Vou ver isso aquí.
Vou fazer uma coisa aquí
antes de lançar.
Com o URL
Eu posso fazer click e
abrir com Firefox.
E agora ele vai
lançar Firefox
e vai rodar o meu aplicativo
"dentro do naveador,"
mas vai me dar a posibilidade
de depuração dentro de Eclipse.
"na verdade, é STS neste caso."
Agora tem muitos componentes
lançados por este IDE
e se quer saber
o que está acontecendo
passa pelas sessões mais tarde
e vamos explicar com muitos detalhes
o que está acontecendo.
É bem bacana.
"Tem algums componentes, algumas"
compilações processando.
Vamos deixar de falar nisso agora.
Queremos focalizar no fato de que
está rodando dentro de Firefox.
E aí vai.
Podemos ver o aplicativo.
"É bem simples, "
mas tem todos os pedaços
de armação que preciso
para começar a criar
o meu aplicativo.
"Tenho a informação,"
"os empregados,"
os gastos.
Eu posso revisá-los
ou gerar outros novos.
Eu posso gerar um empregado novo.
Vamos dá-lo um nome.
Username é Pramsdale.
E um comentário
isso é um demo e não quero
amanezá-lo
"por isso faço click no ""cancel."""
E que vemos aquí
é que diz
"Olha, você tem um formulário."
O formulário tem dados.
Não está armanezado.
Tem certeza que quer sair?
Tudo isso é grátis.
E confirmação do formulário.
"Para repitir, é código repetitivo com que"
não tem que se preocupar.
"Eu disse, ""Tá"
"vou abandonar as alterações."""
E a outra coisa que veem
é  que apertei o back button
"Imediatamente, volto para o lugar"
onde estava. Certo?
Não saí do app.
É a beleza de Ajax.
Tudo é transparente.
Acontece dentro do navegador.
Então a experiência do ponto
de vista do usuário é fantástico.
Mas agora que vimos o que
podemos fazer com este app
vamos construir
e adaptar este app.
Vou voltar para o IDE.
"Tipicamente, o que voce quer fazer"
quando está desenvolvendo o seu app
vai começar com
o seu data model.
O seu data model é onde está
armazenado todos os dados do applicativo.
OK
Essas mudanças são bem simples.
Neste caso vamos atualizar
o empregado.
Vamos colocar um número celular.
Aí está ele.
Agora chamamos esta class
Espera um segundo.
Vamos ir por aquí
e vamos dizer que
tem um display name
Tem um user name
Vamos colocar o celular para ele.
OK. Isso foi uma alteração
bem simples.
Somente acrescentei um field
para ums dos objetos de dados.
Mas o problema é que quando
muda o data model
tipicamente com aplicações grandes
tem muitas consequências.
Tenho que mudar meus views
os meus controladores.
Tenho que mudar o código
para transportar o objeto
É código simples e repetido
que não quero ter que escrever.
Quero concentrar
nos features impressivos.
A coisa linda é que
"no instante que escolho ""save"""
"e armanezar isso dentro do navegador,"
o Roo vai tomar...
vai tomar essas alterações e
propagá-las por todo o aplicativo.
Vamos ver a ação
mais uma vez.
Tenho um erro na aplicação.
Descupla.
Vou tentar mais uma vez.
Vou por aquí
vou criar...
...um private string...
...celular...
Aí está.
Descupla.
E agora você vai ver o Roo
tomar a alteração
e propagá-la
pelo aplicativo
e mudar todas as fichas que mencionei.
É muito bom.
"Agora você vai pensar,"
OK. Gerou esse código para mim.
Mas agora eu tenho que
compilar de novo
E tenho que redeploy
Vai tomar ums minutos.
"E eu vou ler, você sabe,"
"um pouquinho do blog, "
e um pouquinho de twitter
Mas este não é o caso.
Porque somente tenho que
voltar ao aplicativo
"fazer click no ""reload"""
Sim... tenho certeza que quero sair
E aí!
Vocês podem ver aquí
aí está a entrada de celular.
Tudo completo.
Somente tive que fazer uma
alteração e fazer click no save
Uma colaboração muito bom.
"Agora, o caso sutil, "
mas poderoso é que
mesmo que temos muitas
ferramentas para usar
são mais ou menos 6 ou 7
juntos aquí
e toos têm tecnologías específicas
a coisa boa é que
no final do día
geram uma aplicativo que
é construído a base de normas.
Isto compila num WAR file.
Si tiver conhecimento dos web apps
você sabe o que é um WAR file.
E porque está montado com HTML5
Javascript e CSS
posso lançar o aplicativo
onde quiser.
"Posso lançá-lo em nosso cloud,"
Google App Engine.
Posso lançá-lo em ambiente local
como o DMWearZ Fabric.
Você pode lançâ-lo
no cloud que quiser.
A boa coisa é que
a escolha é sua.
E é isso que pensamos
da portabilidade do cloud.
e isso é o esforço nas ferramentas
de desenvolvimento que apoiamos.
"E com isso,"
vamos voltar para o Eric.
[aplausos]
"Eric: Muito obrigado, Chris."
Obrigado.
É isso que temos da sessão
de cloud computing.
Se quiser saber mais
"do Google Web Toolkits,"
"Srping Roo, e App Engine,"
tem mais sessões
ao longo do día.
Vou convidá-lhes para ver o agenda
e assegurar que asistam a essas sessões.
"E como tem visto, espero,"
tem muita coisa estimulante
tanto no front-end
"com navegadores e normas,"
quanto no back-end
com servidores e App Engine.
Mas umas das outras grandes dimensões
do estímulo na web hoje
é o crecimento de mobile
e o crecimento de aceso mobile
da internet.
E quero convidar o Mario
para chegar ao palco
para falar das informes mais recentes
do Android.
Mario.
[aplausos]
We're going to have to get Eric
a caipirinha
a little fried mandioca for him later
so he can taste some
Brazilian food
and a Brazilian drink.
"Well, let's talk about mobile."
I had the opportunity to work
on the Android team
for this last year and a half
more or less
at Google.
And it was a really fascinating
experience to see the growth
of this platform and of the mobile GSS
platform and of the internet in general.
I think that this question
"""Why mobile?"""
two years ago was
more relevant.
"Today I think that everyone already knows,"
"more or less, the answer"
but it's worth talking
about...
about some important facts.
In order to...
to help us understand a little
about the magnitude of opportunity
"of the impact of this technology, let's look"
"at some numbers, some..."
some data.
"First, I think that "
everyone knows there are
more or less 6.8 billion people
on the planet.
But there are 4.1 billion
new mobile devices on the planet.
A huge number.
3/6 billion subscribers to mobile services.
And 1.2 billion PCs.
There are...
almost...
almost 3 and a half times
more mobile devices than PCs.
"This year, for the first time..."
in 2010
for the first time [ ] year
that more people are accessing the internet
for the first time using a mobile device
than using a desktop computer.
Really an incredible thing.
"And it's not only these numbers, but also"
a business opportunity
we're going to go to
business opportunity
is really very big.
We can see here that
the comparison of the size
of this opportunity
with other businesses
that you might know.
There's a big business opportunity.
Now let's look at some other
interesting numbers here
that's really cool.
Let's compare
we know that it's a gigantic market
and that it's growing very fast
but the historical data are going to
give a different perspective.
"Let's look at AOL, which was  "
for a lot of people
mainly in the United States
the first way
the first experience with the internet.
This chart shows the growth
"in 5 years, in 20 quarters, of AOL."
"During this period, AOL reached"
almost 20 million users
a growth that at that time
in the 90s
we thought was
very fast growth.
"In Japan, [ ] like "
iMode was for many
also a very important experience
for online access.
It grew two times faster
"that AOL did,"
reaching 40 million users more or less
during those 5 years.
"Sure, lots of people remember"
some of you may have been
a little young for this
but a lot of people remember
that in terms of a big explosion
of internet use on the web
began with Netscape.
And Netscape's base
or Netscape
it's user base reached a peak
of more than 50 million users
in less than 5 years.
So this growth was even faster
Then came mobile web.
And this is a very recent phenomenon.
The iPhone and iPad made all of this from the
past look like children's toys.
"In four and a half years, the iPhone and iPad"
together have reached
200 million users.
And here's a ...
I think we know...
everyone here has a cellphone
and is accessing the web all the time
but when we see these numbers
is when we really see this phenomenon.
And the story of Android
is much more recent than that.
But its growth is also
extraordinary and apparently sitll
defines new standards of growth
in the technology industry.
"In a short time, the Android"
has reached a growth almost...
almost crazy.
We have...
We can see here
where Android is.
"After 7 months, compared with "
"other technologies,"
what we see is
a really big growth.
Now let's look at Android
in more specific terms.
The mobility we use
is called activations.
The number of new devices
that never used the network
and that are appearing for the first
time on our servers.
And these are only the devices
that we see on our servers.
They aren't implemenations of Android
in China or other places
that aren't compatible and that
don't use Google services.
We announced in February
in Barcelona
that Android had reached
"60,000 activations each day."
"From there, in May"
at the Google IO conference
the worldwide version
of our conference here
we announced that the number
"of activations had reached 100,000."
"In June, it was up to 160,000."
"And then, in August, we announced"
"it had passed 200,000."
There are more...
today we're...
there are more that 1-1/2 million
activations each week.
Really a very big number.
"In terms of applications,"
we also see
this growth.
"From 20,000 apps in February"
"to 50,000 in May,"
"60,000 in June,"
"70,000 in July,"
And last Monday
we announced
that the number of Android apps
"in the Android market surpassed 100,000."
And the...
a we also see
the number of devices.
There are 90 Android devices.
Wehn we were thinking about
those growth curves
it was exactly 2 years ago
in October of 2008
now it's October of 2010
that the first Android device was launched
the G!
"At that time, it was one device from"
one manufacturer from one country.
In October of 2008.
"Two years later, this is"
Android's situation.
And so one thing I want to...
one of the biggest reasons for
Android's growth
is the development
of apps for the platform.
I want to thank all of the
active developers in the Android market
"that are here, I want to thank you"
for your contribution to this growth.
"So after the numbers,"
let's talk about some of the
latest news about Android.
Since we announced all of the
latest about Froyo
"at Google IO, there was..."
we've been launching some new things.
"For example, search suggestions"
on Android Market.
If you do a search
on Android Market today
it will be a little different
and better
than a few months ago.
You'll see suggestions
as you type.
Our goal is to make a search
on Android Market
as good as a search on Google
that you're accustomed to.
And...
and when we talk about
each app
the developer's page
is a new feature.
It allows user comments
to be seen much more easily.
And that page also has statements
with the number of registered
problems for each app.
And it shows details for each app
to help you understand
what's happening with the app.
"Of course, users give permission"
to use this information
and a lot of users give it.
Now another important feature is
server license verification
This is a free service
that allows developers like you
protect yourselves
against piracy.
It's a service that verifies
on the server
that your apps being executed
were really licensed.
This is a very important topic...
so important that this afternoon
there's a special presentation
about the licensing server
that you can see on the schedule.
The next new feature
that we see on...
that we launched in the
last few months is my favorite.
It's cloud messaging:
cloud to device messaging.
It lets you send
a message from your server
or Google's server
and then Google's server sends
a message to the Android device
to execute some action.
This is done with great efficiency
in real time at a very low cost.
This is the same mechanism
used by Gmail.
Before we launched this
to all the developers
the same mechanism used
by Gmail to announce
to inform the device
that new email has arrived.
This is available for all
developers for free.
And a very useful example of this
"is the ""Chrome-to-phone"" plug-in."
I don't know how many of you have
"used the ""Chrome-to-phone"" plug-in"
but it allows you to do something
on Google Chrome.
For example...
you can send
to your phone
your cellphone number
or address and URL
or a map you're looking for
If I go from my house to the
World Trade Center in São Paulo
I go from my house to Google's
office in Mountain View
I look on my Mac
on my home computer
and because I'm logged in
on my Mac
with the same account that
I've logged in with on my Android
I can use Chrome to phone.
It send street informaiton
which roads I take
to the phone.
On the phone
the phone automatically launches
the Turn by Turn Navegation app
that we'll see in just a bit here.
"So this is a very, very cool"
and innovative feature.
And there's also
we also included
a large number of new functions
to improve corporate user's lives.
Eric spoke a little about
the importance
of corporate users when he
talked about App Engine.
And today we're not going into
details here
but this latest information
will help you
"I hope, feel more confident in the"
IT teams
and the IT users on the Android platform
We're going to...
I want to also talk about
what we recently announced.
That's in the area of
payments on Android.
This is something we know:
the monetization of apps
is one of the big problems for
Android developers in the world.
"Because of that, we've invested"
a lot into bringing
the paid version of Android
to more and more countries.
And we're pleased to announce
that the inroads into the
the paid Android market
has changed a lot.
From this version we're seeing
pay attention to the little maps
For this version now.
We've added 20 countries including
Brazil to the paying Android market.
"I hope that it's good for you, too."
And there's more to come.
We have a clear roadmap
for payments on the Android market.
And you should know
that yesterday
yesterday we announced
search by voice and
navigation using Google maps
in Portuguese.
I'd like to invite our Product Manager
here in Brazil to the stage.
Marcelo Quintela.
who participated a lot
in the development of these products
to make a demo to show
this new feature.
"Marcelo Qintela, please."
[aplausos]
Marcelo Quintela: Good.
Good morning.
"Like Mario said,"
yesterday we announced
two new features for Android.
Whoever has had the chance to read
our blogs or our news sites
they refer to the maps
and to search by voice.
I first...
I don't want to take too much
of your time.
I'm only going to show this feature.
"Actually, I invite you to use"
this feature yourselves.
beause it's available beginning
since yesterday on Android cells
1.6 and higher.
"with version 4.5 of maps, the latest"
version you can get from Market
It already has navegation.
And with v. 2.1 and higher
you can get from Market
search by voice
download it and you can use it.
It already exists in English
Since yesterday
it's available in Portuguese.
If you have a Froyo like this that was
launched simultaneously by Motorola
"Froyo v. 2.2, it already comes with"
search by voice installed.
So just to show you quickly
Maps that you...
I imagine most of you already know;
do a search for a point of interest
in the region
You can find it
and if you used Maps
you have already noticed that
you can get directions
from where you are
to a certain place.
you had three options
But if you clicked on
navegation by car
it didn't work.
It wasn't available in Brazil.
As of now
if you click
it'll give you point-to-point navegation.
I'm not going to click here
because I don't have GPS
and I'm not in a car.
But I have a prepared route
to demonstrate the navegation.
Where's the volume?
There are the same
the same features of Maps
that you know
are here on the navegation.
So you have the routes
that you know
In São Pualo
you have traffic information.
If you click this little button here
you'll get to see an aerial view
of how
of the state of the traffic
to your destination.
If you...
About a month ago
we launched Street View.
and so if you want to see
what's the way to your destination
or the twists in the road
you can call up Street View
and see what your route is.
"That way, when you get "
to your destination.
Instead of only telling you
"your destination is 400 meters ahead,"
"your destination is on your right,"
you can...
"you'll see a photo of your destination,"
so you can see where
you're going.
The same searches in Maps work.
If you search for a drugstore
"for example, this search"
is optimized around this route
and you can turn it
"the route, if you want."
And you'll see the drugstores
along the route.
Good.
So everything is available
in Street View
"the satellite view, traffic"
everything you recognize with Maps
now with routes in real time.
with directions in Portuguese.
"turn right, turn left"
"turn around, etc."
This is a product that's not...
directly associated
with development
"on top of that, it also shows"
the investment
that Google's making
in the Android platform.
And you can imagine someone
"at Christmas time, deciding between"
buying a cellphone
a smartphone
or a GPS
That person could choose to buy
two of these at the same time
The other feature
now I'm going to ask
"really, please, "
don't use the Internet
or text from your cellphones
because this really needs
the Internet
If it doesn't work
you'll have to listen to me
tell a joke
or something boring.
Well.
Starting now
when you install search by voice
or if you get a Froyo
that already has it installed
in the Google search boxes you'll see
there's this little microphone
at the side
a lot like in the desktop demo
Eric made.
If you now
click on the microphone
Photos of Ipanema
This is the end because I'm from Rio
I wanted to show off photos of my city
I'm going to try something a little
more complicated and ambitious
How many people were there
at Bon Jovi's show?
"There is is: 65,000 people."
[aplausos]
Good.
And this feature is available
in other apps.
"It's available in Maps,"
on YouTube
Any app with a little search box
now has a microphone there.
We can...
Ivete Sangalo at Madison Square Garden
in New York.
Ivete Sangalo.
There it is
in New York
Good.
Let's watch a video so you can see.
What I wanted to show here
an app I grabbed off the inter...
from Market
from IMDB
It's a third-party app
that's not from Android.
It's an app like you
might have developed.
And it also has a search box.
There's the little microphone.
Tropa de Elite 2
And there's the result.
So if you develop an application
[API] or Speech Intent API
that has a search feature
It will be covered
it's already available
But the interesting thing is that
in a session this afternoon.
Portuguese being understood
from now on you can count on
Not only for the English-speaking public
in all of your applications.
"but for the Brazilian-speaking public, too."
You can use
you can count on the little mike
to make your searches.
being available and you'll be able
"This, since it's been available"
so any application
since yesterday
that you launch starting today
that's on the market
has that feature available.
"Thanks, Mario."
Good.
Can you hear me?
This version not only understands carioca
"but Brazilian portuguese, too."
So you can
you can use them
If you
If you want
[applause]
If you'd like to
before the first presentations begin
meet the Android team
the people are going to be
this afternoon
to be avaiable in the Android lounge
It's a great pleasure to be here.
between 11:15 and 12:15.
It was a great pleasure to participate in this
And we're really
presentation with my colleagues.
when we  say
we're really excited
that we're excited
with the development
it really
platform at Google
is something genuine
that we're working hard
that comes from the heart
to hear from you about
a lot in those areas and we hope
what feedback you have for us
what's going well
"And with that, I hope you have a good day."
so we can improve those areas.
Learn a lot and have fun.
Thank you.
[applause]
01:11:53.267,00:00:00.000